We've seen how to make horizontal and vertical shifts happen for all sorts of
functions. And we've also seen how to reflect in the x and y axis. These types
of transformations are typically refererred to as rigid transformations,
because the basic shape of the graph doesn't change. All we're doing is
translating it around the coordinate plane. Or flipping it over. Only its
position changes. We can also, however, have nonrigid transformations. These
involve the stretching or shrinking of a function. Nonrigid transformations
distort the shape of the original function. We're going to deal with this
stretching and shrinking with something familiar right now. Parabolas. Here are
a bunch of parabolas that have been stretched in different ways. I'd like you
to match each one with the equation it corresponds to. Please write the letter
of the parabola in the proper box.